a man that knows me almost better than  any human being  he knows every inch of me  what  what  and he thinks it's actually a very  beautiful sight that's why i like it  oh my god that's why i like him  he was the white extremely cult-like  and also  for obama and for bush  obama and i'd love to ask him who's in  the best shape  obama  obviously obama  kind of a question is that he  was also an incredible admiral highly  respected by everybody he was a great  admiral he had ever so he was a great  doctor  a great admiral and you know what he is  now he's an idiot incredible  loving wonderful but very tough  politician from texas  congressman ronnie jackson thank you  ronnie